[Musique]
je vis là
on attend
[Musique]
où
soit je vous présente une collection qui
est baptisé opulence mes premiers
modèles sont des modèles qui sont faites
dans les sachets de recyclage cd sachez
que j'ai récupéré dans la rue un peu
partout alors l'objectif est de susciter
des débats autour pour qu'on puisse
parler de la protection de
l'environnement parce que quand ce
vêtement va sortie forcément les gens
vont se poser des questions qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent nous montrer
[Musique]
on
à partir de vieux matériaux chine et à
la prime de vieux stocks d'invendus de
matières naturelles transformer
artisanalement et de vieilles rues
beaudry locales tunisiennes que je
transforme et que je restaure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bref cycling comme pas mal d'autres
choix qui font partie de ce mouvement
des normes de slow fashion qui
s'imposent à nos créateurs d'aujourd'hui
est une manière nouvelle de considérer
les choses d'abord par rapport aux
process par rapport au choix de
matériaux et après par rapport à la
manière dont on peu influent référence
et les habitudes d'usagé de consommation
chez l'usager
[Musique]
new york la ville la plus creuse à
l'hôte clause last ceux d'unibail
[Musique]